[Música]
bienvenidos a esta emisión especial en
francés 24 de las noticias del 2020 un
año marcado por una pandemia que llevó a
los países a tomar medidas sin
precedentes y ocupó los titulares
mundiales durante muchos meses pero
también hubo otras noticias que marcaron
estos 365 días este especial hace un
recorrido por las noticias del año
el 2020 estará marcado por el estallido
contra la violencia policial y el
racismo las protestas que comenzaron en
mayo en eeuu tras la muerte de georg
floyd se extendieron por todo el mundo
en ciudades francesas colombianas y
mexicanas las manifestaciones se
enlazaron con casos locales
el coronavirus suspendió algunas
elecciones pero a pesar de la pandemia
se celebraron históricos comicios en
chile bolivia y estados unidos país
donde donato un pasará a la historia
como uno de los cuatro presidentes que
no ha sido reelecto a pesar de que
desplegó una guerra legal para lograrlo
después de meses de incertidumbre y al
borde de la fecha límite la unión
europea y el reino unido cerraron un
acuerdo histórico sobre su relación tras
el divorcio logrando evitar un final
caótico al proceso del break sit
[Música]
2020 es un año como ningún otro la
pandemia ha cambiado nuestra vida de una
manera que hubiera sido inimaginable
hace dos meses poniendo de rodillas a
las economías del mundo en el 2020 el
kobe 19 dejó más de 80 millones de
personas contagiadas y al menos un
millón setecientos cincuenta y cuatro
mil muertos así comenzó todo
cuando empezó el 2020 la organización
mundial de la salud ya hablaba de un
nuevo coronavirus el 11 de enero de 2020
china anunció su primera muerte un
hombre de 61 años a quien se identificó
como cliente de un mercado en la ciudad
de buján a pesar de los primeros
reportes de una misteriosa enfermedad
parecida a la neumonía millones de
personas viajaron por el nuevo año lunar
la más grande celebración china días
después yohan fue declarada en
cuarentena pero el peligroso virus ya
había salido de china poniendo de
rodillas a los sistemas de salud de
varias naciones europeas y asiáticas
después del primer caso detectado en
brásil el coronavirus tardó menos de un
mes en extenderse por toda américa
latina el 20 de marzo cuando haití
confirmó sus primeros dos casos el
comité 19 hacía presencia oficial en
todos los países de la región de abruzzo
jasbir singh de scouts break la
organización mundial de la salud ha
estado evaluando este brote durante todo
el tiempo y estamos profundamente
preocupado
tanto por los alarmantes niveles de
propagación y gravedad como por los
niveles de inacción por lo tanto hemos
determinado que el kobe 19 puede
caracterizarse como una pandemia edad
cobit nineteen camby caracteres als
pandémica
las noticias que siguieron tras de ser
declarado como pandemia parecían sacadas
de una película de ciencia ficción
colapsos en los mercados países en
cuarentena la activación del teletrabajo
inestabilidad de las bolsas naciones
declaradas en emergencia suspensiones de
los juegos olímpicos' y de todos los
grandes eventos sociales deportivos y
culturales a pesar de que se tomaron
medidas gubernamentales inéditas la
crisis seguía con los casos en aumento
entre los millones de contagiados nos
enterábamos de los positivos de
políticos como el primer ministro de
reino unido el mandatario de honduras la
presidenta interina de bolivia el
mandatario de brasil o el presidente de
eeuu la crisis sanitaria mundial además
de generar un enorme costo humano está
llevando a la recesión global más
profunda desde la segunda guerra mundial
para muchos el camino para aproximarse a
una nueva normalidad son las vacunas por
lo que el panorama en 2021 es
esperanzador ante la llegada de las
fórmulas contra el kobe de 19 las
vacunaciones masivas ya han comenzado
desde diciembre el coronavirus fue el
máximo protagonista pero también el año
tuvo otros temas el 2020 comenzó con
tensiones entre irán y eeuu luego de que
el general qasem soleimani el más
poderoso militar iraní muriera cerca del
aeropuerto de bagdad en un ataque
ordenado por el presidente de donald
trump el pentágono dijo que tenía como
objetivo disuadir planes de agresión las
tensiones llevaron a que irán derribará
accidentalmente un avión ucraniano
dejando a sus 176 pasajeros fallecidos
el líder supremo iraní alí jamenéi se
disculpó posteriormente por el de arriba
en mayo estallaron las manifestaciones
contra el racismo y la violencia
policial tras la muerte de georg floyd
en eeuu este caso revivió las denuncias
acumuladas contra las fuerzas de
seguridad y expuso la discriminación que
aún se vive en diversos países
bueno
me gusta la compañía
no puedo respirar fueron las palabras de
george frey tras ser arrestado y
sometido por la policía luego de su
violenta detención en minneapolis
estallaron en mayo las protestas en eeuu
derecha bing el policía que fue grabado
por transeúntes poniendo su rodilla en
el cuello del afroamericano fue acusado
de asesinato en tercer grado y homicidio
involuntario para junio las protestas
protagonizaron graves incidentes frente
a la casa blanca y tras decretarse
'toque de queda' la policía dispersó a
los manifestantes
el caso generó una ola de indignación a
nivel mundial las sedes diplomáticas
estadounidenses en ciudades de varios
países fueron escenarios de
manifestaciones georgia se convirtió
después en el epicentro de la ira tras
difundirse vídeos de otros arrestos
policiales
richard brooks quien tras resistirse a
los policías fue abatido a tiros en
otros países las manifestaciones se
enlazaron con casos locales en europa
varias estatuas de líderes esclavistas
fueron derribadas
en brasil el movimiento black lives
matters se manifestó contra la policía
de la nación sudamericana considerada
una de las más violentas del mundo
mientras que en mexico manifestantes
enfurecidos atacaron el palacio del
gobierno de jalisco tras la muerte de
giovanni lópez de 24 años el joven cuyo
oficio era albañil fue detenido
violentamente por no usar cubrebocas el
4 de mayo y murió posteriormente bajo el
curso de policial
en septiembre colombia vivió noches de
disturbios y protestas contra la
brutalidad policial tras la muerte del
abogado javier ordóñez sometido
violentamente por la policía en la vía
pública lo que llevó a cientos de
personas de las calles de la capital y
en otras ciudades colombianas
registrándose enfrentamientos entre los
manifestantes y los agentes el 13 de
septiembre las autoridades de bogotá
convocaron un acto para pedir perdón a
las familias de las 13 personas muertas
y a los cientos de heridos que dejaron
varios días de protestas contra la
brutalidad policial que derivaron en más
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad el caso de freud se convirtió
en un símbolo contra el racismo y la
violencia policial y fue un tema
principal de la campaña electoral rumbo
a las presidenciales estadounidenses
también en 2020 continuaron las
protestas en hong kong contra el plan de
china de imponer una nueva legislación
de seguridad en el territorio
semiautónomo las manifestaciones masivas
se retomaron desde mayo el 6 de
septiembre casi 300 personas fueron
detenidas en hong kong mientras
protestaban en contra del aplazamiento
de las elecciones parlamentarias la
policía disparó balas de goma para
dispersar a los manifestantes varias
figuras de la oposición
no recibieron autorización para
presentarse a las elecciones
legislativas y decenas de activistas
prodemocracia han sido acusados o
detenidos
en agosto ocurrió una tragedia en el
puerto de beirut que causó la muerte de
más de 200 personas
así se escucho la inmensa explosión de
más de 2.000 toneladas de nitrato de
amonio miles de ciudadanos exigieron la
renuncia de las autoridades por el
suceso y por su actuar en las
posteriores protestas que dejaron un
expolicía muerto y más de 200 heridos
hasan diab quien dimitió a raíz de las
protestas desencadenadas tras la
tragedia pero continúa como primer
ministro encargado fue imputado en
diciembre junto a otros tres ex
ministros por el juez que investiga la
explosión por negligencia y por causar
la muerte de más de 200 personas
la gestión de donald trump de la
pandemia así como su respuesta a las
protestas tras el asesinato de georg
floyd influyeron en su derrota electoral
en las elecciones estadounidenses una de
las figuras del 2020 fue yo byte primero
logrando la victoria en la carrera
demócrata y después en las
presidenciales esto a pesar de que a
inicios de año pocos apostaban por él
después de resultados decepcionantes en
los caucus de iowa y en las primarias de
needham ser la candidatura de joe biden
parecía destinada al fracaso
el demócrata argumentó que las cosas
cambiarían tan pronto como los
afroamericanos comenzaran a votar en
masa tenía razón arrasó en carolina del
sur lo que hizo que varios demócratas se
apartarán su último rival el senador de
izquierda bernie sanders se retiró en
abril lo que le permitió a bailén
enfocarse en france mientras que el
presidente restaba importancia a la
amenaza de la pandemia sin lograr
tranquilizar a los estados
trump también se enfrentó al creciente
movimiento social a raíz de la muerte
del afroamericano georg floyd por parte
de un oficial de la policía de
mineápolis las encuestas mostraron que
los estadounidenses apoyaron en gran
medida las protestas pacíficas por la
justicia racial
con este telón de fondo o bailén eligió
a kamala harris como su compañera de
fórmula desde el senado harris había
impulsado reformas policiales faltando
menos de dos meses para las
presidenciales la muerte de la
emblemática jueza de la corte suprema
ruth báder ginsburg generó más polémica
en la escena política del país a pesar
de que los demócratas pedían que su
reemplazo fuera nominado por el
presidente electo amy cón y barrett
designada por trump se convirtió en la
nueva jueza de la corte suprema y
llegaron los debates el primero fue el
caótico con constantes interrupciones el
segundo fue cancelado debido al contagio
y hospitalización por kobe 19 de donald
trump y después de la debacle del primer
cara a cara la comisión optó en el
último debate por silenciar los
micrófonos de los participantes cuando
su oponente estaba hablando
después del esperado 3 de noviembre joe
biden resultó electo acumulo 306 votos
electorales superando los 270 necesarios
frente a los 232 de trump el trump sin
embargo no ha cedido y ha afirmado
falsamente que un fraude le arrebató un
segundo mandato en la casa blanca
ninguno de sus esfuerzos ha tenido éxito
el 2020 fue un año histórico para chile
tras meses de exigencia ciudadana de
cambiar la constitución heredada de la
dictadura militar de augusto pinochet un
año después del estallido social que
sacudió al país chile volvió a ser
escenario de masivas protestas
antigubernamentales exigiendo un cambio
constitucional miles de personas se
manifestaron contra el gobierno de
sebastián piñera y la caída de un joven
al río puso nuevamente el actuar
policial en el centro de las miradas el
25 de ese mismo mes de octubre los
chilenos aprobaron de manera contundente
cambiar la constitución en el histórico
plebiscito
[Música]
hasta ahora la constitución nos ha
dividido a partir de hoy todos debemos
colaborar para que la nueva constitución
sea el gran marco de unidad de
estabilidad y de futuro y en noviembre
luís arse fue investido como nuevo
presidente de bolivia de esta manera
regresó al poder el movimiento al
socialismo el partido del ex presidente
evo morales que se vio forzado a
renunciar a la presidencia tras los
comicios de 2019 entre denuncias de
fraude electoral y un presunto golpe de
estado en su contra tras permanecer en
méxico y argentina evo morales regresó a
bolivia el 9 de noviembre a 364 días de
su partida en una multitudinaria
caravana
este año pero tuvo tres presidentes de
hecho en una misma semana el 17 de
noviembre francisco sagasti fue
juramentado como mandatario interino
tras la renuncia de manuel merino en
medio de protestas quien asumió solo por
horas la presidencia peruana tras la
destitución en el congreso de martín
vizcarra la vertiginosa sucesión
presidencial fue la consecuencia de una
crisis política más antigua que estuvo
acompañada de una crisis económica y
sanitaria sin precedentes y es que
después de años de crecimiento económico
perú experimentó una contracción y la
pandemia impactó duramente al país con
una de las mayores tasas de mortalidad
en el mundo
durante los últimos años nuestra clase
política es decir muchos de los que
estamos aquí entre otros entre muchos
otros no hemos estado a la altura de los
grandes desafíos que hemos y estamos
enfrentando y para finalizar el break
sito ocurrió este año cuando el reino
unido- abandonó la unión europea el 31
de enero de 2020 pero los negociadores
se dieron 11 meses para definir cómo se
regirían sus relaciones tras el divorcio
los derechos de pesca las reglas de
competencia y la forma como se
resolverán las disputas mantuvieron
estancados los avances tras largas
negociaciones y en la recta final de
concretarse la salida
londres y bruselas alcanzaron un acuerdo
para la relación después del divorcio lo
que evita un final caótico al proceso
del éxito
straight to get away hemos completado el
mayor acuerdo comercial hasta el momento
por valor de 660 mil millones de libras
al año un acuerdo de libre comercio
integral al estilo de canadá entre el
reino unido y la unión europea un
acuerdo que protegerá los empleos en el
país
un acuerdo que permitirá que los
productos del reino unidos sean vendidos
sin tarifas ni cuotas en el mercado
europeo un acuerdo que permitirá a
nuestras compañías exportadoras hacer
aún más negocios con nuestros amigos
europeos
y finalmente hemos llegado a un acuerdo
winding road' fue un camino largo y
tortuoso pero tenemos mucho que mostrar
eres ser feliz es justo es un acuerdo
equilibrado y es lo correcto y
responsable para ambas partes o sites
estas noticias son una muestra de que el
2020 no estuvo marcado únicamente por la
pandemia el año nos deja muchos
aprendizajes como la importancia de
cuidar nuestra salud física y mental les
deseamos un gran 2021 y que esas
lecciones las llevemos con nosotros en
el nuevo año muchas gracias por su
compañía siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]